YURI: Do you develop distributed
applications, or systems made
up of lots of microservices?
If so, you've surely
had to deal with issues
where users complain about
the service being slow.
In a distributed
system it's often
hard to figure out which
dependency is causing it.
This is where distributed
tracing comes in.
Recover using OpenTelemetry
to capture and analyze latency
from distributed applications
in the previous episode.
If you haven't watched
it, we'll link to it
in the episode notes.
But in brief, we want to create
traces for user requests,
and spans for the service,
the service requests
whose latency we want to analyze
to determine which services may
be contributing the most
to the overall latency
experienced by our users.
OpenTelemetry is an
open source library
that allows us to easily
instrument our services,
and capture traces from.
My name is Yuri.
I'm an SRE at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going
to show you two ways
to instrument your services
with OpenTelemetry.
I'll cover easily
getting started
with automatic
instrumentation, and using
manual instrumentation
for maximum control.
Welcome back to Engineering
for Reliability.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's have a look at a
simple application that
has a front end that
serves user requests,
and makes its own
request to a back end
to retrieve additional data.
We'll use this for both
of our examples today.
So ideally, we want
to capture the latency
of the overall
request as perceived
by the user, the latency
of the back end request
as seen by the front end,
and how long the back end
processing takes.
The front end of our
application is written in Flask,
and it uses a request library
to make back end calls.
The back end is
also a Flask app.
When it receives a request,
it does some processing
before returning a response.
To use automatic
instrumentation,
we can run both our
front end and back end
using the OpenTelemetry
instrument command.
The command will try
to automatically detect
packages use bar code, and
apply automatic tracing
instrumentation on them.
We get distributed tracing
exported to Cloud Trace
without having to
make any code changes.
Let's take a look.
Our front end is running
locally using the OpenTelemetry
instrument command,
instructing you
to send tracers to Cloud Trace.
And the back end is
running locally as well
using the same command.
Let's send a request
to our application
and confirm the response.
In the Cloud Trace UI, we
can find the resulting trace.
It's comprised of
multiple spans.
The root span is
the overall request.
And we can see how long it took.
It was made to our service
running a local host
on port 8080.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first child span
is the back end request
that was also made
to local host,
but on port 8081, which
is where our back end
service is running.
So this is how you
can use OpenTelemetry
automatic instrumentation
to capture traces
across distributed
services without the need
to modify application
code at all.
That was really easy.
But there is a caveat.
We couldn't create a custom
span to time back end processing
without adding
instrumentation in the code.
So let's have a look
at how you can manually
instrument your service
to explicitly control
how spans are created.
We'll link to the full code
sample in the episode notes.
But let's start by reviewing
our front end code.
First, we need to import
the necessary OpenTelemetry
libraries that will let us
manage spans and context
propagation between
our services.
We'll use the request
context to send information
about our trace to the
back end, so that it
can append its own spans to it.
Next, we configure our exporter
to send traces to Cloud Trace.
Finally, we're ready to
make our back end request.
We create our root
span that will
serve as the parent for
the subsequent spans.
Next, we create a
span specifically
to time how long the
back end request takes.
Lastly, we make a
request with HTTP headers
that will carry the spam
context to our back end.
In our back end
service, we first
extract the spam context from
the incoming request headers.
We then create a dedicated
spam using that context to time
how long our back end
processing task takes.
Now, let's run our services
and inspect our trace
in Cloud Trace.
In this example, we also have
our front end running locally.
But this time, we're using
the basic Python command.
Our back end is also running
locally using the same command.
We can confirm that
our application
is responding by
sending a request
and confirming the response.
Now, we can go to Cloud
Trace and find the resulting
trace in the trace list.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The trace has our root span, the
back end request span, and now,
a dedicated span for
back end processing.
For each of these, we
can see exactly how long
they took, which
allows us to figure out
exactly where the time is spent
in serving the user request.
So this is how you can
use manual instrumentation
with OpenTelemetry to send a
request context over the wire,
and use it to a open child
spans from downstream services.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how to use
both automatic and manual
instrumentation with
OpenTelemetry for distributed
tracing of our Python services,
and understand latency
in distributed application.
I hope this helps you to
keep your services reliable,
and your users happy.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]